وتواصل الجاليه التركيه في فرنسا التصويت
في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات التركيه
منذ السبت الماضي بعد انحسار التنافس بين
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان مرشح تحالف
الجمهور ومنافسه زعيم المعارضه
مرشحي تحالف الشعر من المقرر ان تنتهي
اليوم عمليه التصويت في القنصليه التركيه
المنتشره في كبريات المدن الفرنسيه مثل
باريس ومارسيليا
وتعتبر الجاليه التركيه في فرنسا من بين
اكبر الجليات في اوروبا بعد المانيا بما
يقارب اربع مئه الف ناخب وكانت الجوله
الاولى من الانتخابات الرئاسيه قد سجلت
مشاركه قويه حصل خلالها الرئيس اردوغان
على ما يزيد عن 64% من اصوات الجاليه
التركيه في فرنسا
وفي المانيا يدلي افراد الجاليه التركيه
باصواتهم في اليوم الاخير من تصويت الخارج
في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه ويجري التصويت في مراكز مخصصه
للجاليه التركيه في سبعه عشره مدينه في
عموم المانيا ويحق لنحو مليون ونصف تركي
ونصف مليون تركي من المقيمين في المانيا
التصويت من مجمل افراد الجاليه التركيه
البالغ عددها نحو ثلاثه ملايين ونصف مليون
شخص
للمتابعه معنا من داخل مركز الاقتراع
المركزي لولايتي برلين
وبرانديمبورغ مراسل الجزيره عيسى الطيبي
ومن امام القنصليه التركيه بمدينه
بولون بيانكور المتاخمه لباريس مراسل
الجزيره حضر مريح ونبدا من
المانيا مع عيسى طيبه واجواء
الانتخابات في الجوله الثانيه جوله
الاعاده
حسن الساعات المتبقيه هي ساعات مفصليه
بالنسبه لاتراك المانيا لنبدا من موقع
الحال في هذا المكان
برلين المركز الاقترن مركز اختراع المركز
في برلين وبراد الى غايه اللحظه مساء
اليوم تم تسجيلك اكثر من 58 الف مقتنع
اليوم كما تقول لنا
هنا في مركز اختراع بانهم يتوقعون ان يصوت
نحو سته الاف ناخب هذا اليوم في هذا
المركز فقط الذي يجمع بين الولايتين اهميه
هذا المركز لربما تبدو واضحه وتعكس ايضا
حده الصراع في الانتخابات التركيه في
المانيا في هذا المركز تفوق الرئيس التركي
بفارق 200 صوت فقط في الانتخابات الماضيه
حصل على
49.25% اما غريمه منافسه مرشح
حصل على نسبه
48.75
وهذا يدل بان الفارقه كان ضئيلا جدا لم
يتجاوز 200 صوت النقطه الاخرى بان
المسجلين في ولايه براد ونتحدث بان
العاصمه
يتقدم فيها تتقدم فيها جيوب حزب الشعب
التركي الجمهوري ويتقدمون ايضا بسبب وجود
لهم قوي في هذه المنطقه على خلاع على خلاف
المناطق الغربيه نتحدث عن دورتموند ومنطقه
الرور نزولا الى كولونيا حيث يتواجد اكثر
حزب العداله والتنميه ايضا ما ايضا ما
يمكن قراءته ايضا في انتخابات هذه المره
ان فرانكفورت ايضا كانت واضحه في جوله
الاعاده حيث حيث احتشد الكثير من افراد
الجاليه وكما قالت الشرطه هناك بانها
بانها سابقه ان ترى هذه المسافه الضخمه من
الطوابير المتقدمه الى هذه الانتخابات في
عموم
ونزولا الى المنطقه الشرقيه تبدو يبدو
اليوم الاخير هادئا خصوصا اذا ما استطعنا
لربما هذه الصور حسب ورائي ترى بان
الاقبال لم يكن محتشدا مثل ايام السابقه
هناك حضور نعم لكنه لم يكن مثل الايام
السابقه وهذا طبعا لاسباب كثيره اولا بان
اليوم هو يوم عمل وبان هذا الامر لم يمنع
حتى من الناخبين بان يقتلوا باصواتهم
المكاتب تبدو تعمل كالعاده وايضا الاقبال
موجود لكنه لا يمكن مقارنته بعطله نهايه
الاسبوع وهذا يدل على ان الاتراك فعلا في
المانيا مندمجون متحدون على الادلاب
باصواتهم بمختلف تيارتهم
في فرنسا حافظ مربح عن نسب المشاركه ايضا
هناك في هذه الانتخابات
وعن توجهات الناخبين بالنسبه
للمرشحين لهذه لرئاسه تركيا
نعم مريم تتواصل عمليات التصويت هنا لليوم
الخامس والاخير هنا في قنصليه في قنصليه
تركيا بمدينه بولون بيونكور القريبه من
باريس وهي القنصليه الرئيسيه هنا في محيط
العاصمه باريس تتواصل عمليه الاقتراع يغلق
ابواب القنصليه وينتهي التصويت اليوم في
حدود الساعه العاشره مساء بالتوقيت المحلي
الى حد الان عمليه التصويت تتواصل بطريقه
طبيعيه ولكن الاقبال ليس كما كان عليه
خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع الماضي عمليه
التصويت متواصله ولكن اعداد الناخبين اقل
بكثير مما كانت عليه خلال اليوم الاول
السبت او يوم الاحد
الماضيين عندما
وصل اعداد كبيره من الناخبين الاتراك
وكانت الطوابير تصل الى حتى
الشوارع المحيطه بالقنصليه اليوم المستوى
اقل من ذلك بكثير وهو امر مفهوم لان جزء
كبير من الناخبين كانوا قد توجهوا نحو
مراكز الاقتراع سواء هذا المركز حيث نقف
او عده مراكز اخرى في عمومي فرنسا في
كوبرا المدن الفرنسيه وعددها 5 من بينها
مارسيليا
كانوا قد صوتوا خلال نهايه الاسبوع في هذا
المركز ثم نحو 151 الف مواطن تركي يدون
باصواتهم في حين ان مجموعه الناخبين في كل
فرنسا هو يبلغ نحو
397 الف ناخب اي نحو 400 الف ناخذ من
مجموع نحو 700 الف مواطن تركي يعيشون هنا
في فرنسا خلال الدور الاول الذي شهد ايضا
اقبالا قويا لكن تجدر الاشاره الى ان
الاقبال يوصف باكبر واقوى خلال هذا الدور
الثاني حصل الرئيس رجب طيب بردوغان هنا في
فرنسا على اكثر من
64% من الصوت النخبين في مقابل اكثر من
34% من الاصوات لمنافسه كيلجار اوغلو نعم
مدينه بولونيا المتاخمه لباريس
وعصيب من داخل مركز الاختراع المركزي
لولايتين برلين وبراند شكرا لكما